where does the Nobel Prize fit into all
of this
you know if you think hundreds of years
from now
I venture to say that people will not
remember the winners of a prize
but they'll remember Creations like
these maybe I'm romanticizing
engineering
but I guess I want to ask how important
is the Nobel Prize in all this
um well that's a it's a complicated
question it's uh
as a physicist it's something if you're
if you're trying to win a Nobel Prize
forget it because they give you know one
a year so there's like there's been 200
physicists who have won the Nobel Prize
since 1900 and yeah and so that's
you know and so things just have to fall
right so your goal cannot be to win a
Nobel Prize it wasn't my dream uh it's a
it's uh tremendous for science I mean
why the Nobel Prize for a guy that made
dynamite and stuff is you know what it
is it's a long story but it's the one
day a year where actually the science
that people have done is all over the
world and so forth forget about the
people again you know it is really good
for for science celebrating science it
celebrates science for you know several
days different fields uh you know
chemistry medicine and so forth and uh
everybody doesn't understand everything
about these they're generally fairly
abstract but then it's you know it's on
the front page of newspapers around the
world so it's really good for science
it's not easy to get science on the
front page of the New York Times it's
not there uh should be but it's not
and uh uh so the Nobel Prize is
important in that way uh it's otherwise
you know I have a certain celebrity that
I didn't have before
um
and now you get to be a celebrity that
advertises science it's a mechanism to
uh to remind us how incredible well how
much credit science deserves in
everything well it has a little bit more
one thing I didn't expect which is good
is that you know we have a a government
yeah I'm not picking on ours necessarily
but it's true of all governments are not
run by scientists in our case it's run
by uh lawyers and businessmen yep okay
uh and at best they may have a an aid or
something that knows a little science so
um so our country is and all countries
are hardly uh to hardly take into
account science
in making decisions yes okay and uh
having a Nobel Prize the uh
people in those positions actually
listen
so you have more influence I don't care
whether it's about global warming or
what the issue is there's some influence
which is lacking otherwise and uh I
people pay attention to what I say if I
talk about global warming and they
wouldn't have uh before I had the Nobel
Prize
uh yeah this is very true you're like
the celebrities who talk uh
celebrity has power uh celebrity has
power and that's that's and that's a
good thing that's a good thing yeah uh
singling out people a man on the other
side of it singling up people has all
kinds of you know whether it's for an
Academy Awards or for this have
unfairness and arbitrariness and so
forth and so on so uh
you know that's the other side of the
coin just like you said especially with
the huge experimental projects like this
you know it's a large team and it does
the nature of the Nobel prizes singles
out a few individuals to represent the
team yeah
nevertheless it's a beautiful thing